it's great to welcome to the program
today dan Harris is the author of
meditation for fidgety skeptics and also
the book 10% happier which I read a
couple years ago I think at this point
is also an ABC news anchor who I mean I
I hate to say Dan you're known for
anything in particular but you you came
to mindfulness after what would I guess
we we now have determined was a panic
attack on air some years ago that's
exactly right
I don't mind being known for it at least
at least not now that I've kind of
reframed it if that was just Dan Harris
known for freaking out on the air full
stop that would kind of suck but yeah
the panic attack led me in a weird and
windy way to meditation which has been
incredibly valuable to me but the story
of the panic attack basically is that I
was on the air on Good Morning America
one warm June morning in two of 2004 and
found myself unable to speak which is
inconvenient if you want to anchor the
news and after the panic attack I went
to a doctor who asked me a bunch of
questions and one of the questions was
do you do drugs right and I said yeah
and the story there is that I had spent
a lot of time as a young ambitious
correspondent in war zones after 9/11 I
was in Iraq and Afghanistan etc etc and
I'd come home gotten depressed and I
didn't even know I was depressed and
then blindly self-medicated with
recreational drugs and even though I
wasn't high on the air and I wasn't even
doing drugs that frequently was enough
to change my brain chemistry / this
doctor and so that was a big wake-up
call for me and had a lot of positive
impact and was so when this happened
when the actual acute incident happened
you believe that it was because of other
it wasn't the stress of being on air or
the fear of having a problem speaking on
air that perpetuated it it was just sort
of how the stress that was going on
elsewhere in your life manifested I
think I think for me they're always
there had and is there had been and
still is a baseline amount of
nerves when it comes to speaking
publicly right so but but the the
changes to my brain chemistry just made
my ability to manage the underlying
nerves much worse and when people don't
understand what it means to have a panic
attack because to a lot of people who
don't don't get it it seems like well
hold on you just tell yourself you're
fine and then that's it and just resent
her in that way that's not the way it
works no no no I wish a panic you can
think about as just a malfunction of the
very useful fight-or-flight impulse that
we all have which we evolved for often
when we came face-to-face with the
saber-toothed tiger or something like
that
the brain was flooded with adrenaline
the body had a you know the heart starts
to race there are a lot of very
evolutionarily sound things that happen
in the body that prepare us to fight or
run away in our modern context we're
often having this fight-or-flight
impulse triggered to one extent or
another inappropriately in traffic in a
meeting with our boss while on social
media etc etc it doesn't always escalate
to a panic attack but it can create
background levels of stress that are
really corrosive to our health in
extreme cases when you have panic
disorder as I do it can result in a
full-on panic attack where you are it
runs away it enters into a kind of
vicious cycle where the body is having
this response the mind freaks out in
response to the body's response the body
then gets worse the mind gets worse the
body gets worse the mind gets worse and
off we go into out of the zone of stress
and into the zone of panic I want to be
careful in how I ask this question and
this applies to me as much as it applies
to you but how much of a predisposition
to this could be I don't know if I want
to say cultural or I mean listen Jewish
neuroticism is something that in my
family right I mean I think we know you
know what I'm getting at here which is
there's a lot about upbringing there's a
lot about expectations there's all of
this baggage that people tend to arrive
as adults with that comes from earlier
in life what could there be cultural
components to predisposition to some
degree look I'm not an expert on this
stuff I'm half-jewish
I was raised my dad's Jewish my mother's
a wasp and it's a little bit like that
movie Annie Hall if you ever seen Woody
Allen and yeah in that way and so my dad
had an expression that he used which was
the price of security is insecurity
which is kind of a veneration of anxiety
and you know for a variety of reasons
anxiety is quite common among Jewish
people I think there there may be
something very powerful to the argument
that historic persecution can lead to a
hyper vigilance and that gets handed
down inter generationally so I think
there's a lot going on there plus you
have the the Jewish cultural trait of
really wanting to be successful and so I
think if you combine all of that which
by the way was there on the other side
of my other than the non-jewish side of
my family tree as well and by the way if
you look at my family tree it's just
filled with a lot of people who have
depression and/or addiction so it's a
pretty ripe environment in my case for
you know freaking out there's a debate
that exists and I've interviewed people
on both sides of it including speaking
to folks like Johann Hari who has
written about anxiety and depression
anyway there's this debate about like
how much of this is physiological how
much of it is something that has become
more common because of sort of Western
society that includes it doesn't have to
be just apps and phones it doesn't have
to be getting ahead or or keeping up
with the Joneses but sort of like this
package of realities that that exist do
you have any insight into that from what
you've experienced are these all factors
maybe to different degrees for different
people yeah I like Johann Hari I've had
him
my podcast and as I understand I'm gonna
try to my apologies to Johan if I
reproduce his thesis unfaithfully but
yeah my understanding is his argument is
yes there are physiological genealogical
factors too that can contribute to
things like depression but the way we've
structured society he argues is actually
perhaps an even bigger contributor he
talks about junk values we have junk
food we also have junk values and the
value of individualism which he argues
we've taken too far in Western culture
where we it's all about the myth of the
rugged individual divorced from the
incredible wellspring of of relay
interconnection and human relationship
and community and when community withers
when our emphasis on relationships
withers we get stuck in loneliness and
solace ISM and that can lead to
depression and in my case I would say
it's all of that I want to get to the
meditation piece and mindfulness piece
in a second but a couple other things
just to touch on first so all these
videos now are going viral of you know
the stuff the Costco's and the people
saying they're not going to wear masks
and confrontations that are just
completely horrifying in a number of
different ways and like politic I have
my political view of of it but then also
politics aside these are this is just
clear these are people who are not in a
good place in a bunch of different ways
more than likely that go beyond just
your view about masks do you see any of
the panic type elements in some of these
these rants where people seem to be
almost like outside of their own bodies
acting in ways that they claim they
never have in public settings I I see so
much in this in these videos I see the
panic or sort of you know losing being
hijacked by the reptilian folds of your
brain by the by the what's called the
amygdala the stress center of the brain
so I see that I see again this
of individualism where we don't have any
responsibilities to our neighbors and I
see a kind of twisting of masculinity
because in particular at least one study
shows that men are more likely to resist
mask-wearing than women and in and you
know I don't know how I feel about the
term toxic masculinity just because I
feel like it sometimes gets used in a
really finger-wagging way and I'm not
big on finger-wagging but I do think
that it we are due for a rethink of
masculinity which has often been you
know rejecting what anybody tells me
what to do rejecting being in touch with
your emotions and in fact this idea and
I say this is a guy who never wanted to
be in touch with his emotions ever at
all and that thought it was just
annoying and disgusting we shouldn't
talk about it but in fact emotions are
there nonetheless they are
non-negotiable they are physiological if
that I would argue that the the baller
thing to do the most manly thing to do
is to actually tune into the chaos of
your own mind so that you are not owned
by it and in the press and that process
if you were to look at your shame your
fat your vanity your selfishness and be
okay with it you have a warmer
relationship to your own ugliness which
we all have you would wear a mask right
and it seems like this is now I want to
start to get into the path into
mindfulness and meditation but in
getting to where you eventually get or
describe being at the end of the book
10% happier you talk about this journey
through you know the sort of whoo that
is that is inherent in in some of these
fields and healing and wellness and all
of this different stuff and what I would
consider scammers although I don't know
that you you necessarily use that word
in the book is that I mean from if you
don't know anything about meditation and
mindfulness and you've just kind of
gotten to pictures of it one is that's
for girly men so to speak to take a kind
of meme that spreads or it's Rou you
would probably be predisposed to
this that as as many people do yeah I
think they say exactly right I think
that's probably why no not probably that
is certainly why I was rejecting it
initially because it I because as I
often say meditation has been the victim
of the worst marketing campaign for
anything ever the traditional art around
the traditional depictions of meditation
you know show people sitting on you know
top of a mountaintop you know on top of
a mountain wearing loincloth with a
beatific look on their face etc etc that
is not the experience of meditation for
most people that I know for most people
that I know you can think about
meditation is a kind of exercise for the
brain and for the mind where you are
training the mind in certain skills and
the the animating insight for me the the
thing I'm about to tell you which it
which was electrifying for me which is
why I've been doing why I've been doing
this practice personally for more than a
decade and writing books about it and
having a podcast on and having a
meditation app and blah blah blah the
reason I do all of this is because what
the science is showing us the science
the scientific research into people who
meditate is that the mind and the brain
are trainable that you are not stuck
with your characteristics like factory
settings that are unalterable that the
that happiness compassion generosity
connection these are all skills that can
be trained and that is a radical and
empowering notion one of the things that
I wonder if you would agree can be tough
for people is everybody wants results
and you want to feel and see results but
this is like a really slow-moving thing
it's sort of like you know start a
glacier moving a couple of inches a year
or something like that and and I wonder
if in your experience people abandon
their practice because from day to day
or even month to month it doesn't really
feel like that much is necessarily
changing yeah I think this is a big
issue so yeah it is both slow and it's
not
so for example
well I've had this when when my book
first came out six years ago my first
book came out six years ago I started
saying this thing which was meditate for
a month everyday or daily ish and if by
the end of that time you see no benefit
send me a note on Twitter and tell me
I'm a [ __ ] right people tell me I'm a
[ __ ] all the time right but for other
reasons maybe yes I do think that if you
do it consistently for a short for a few
weeks or a few months you will notice
that your inner weather becomes Baumer
you're not so yanked around by this
inner conversation that you are having
with yourself which if we broadcast
aloud you would be locked up right most
of us aren't even aware that we have
this inner narrator this malevolent
puppeteer that's you know giving us
terrible ideas all the time so I
actually do think you can derive some of
the advertised benefits of meditation
self-awareness calm compassion focus in
a few weeks but but that take that
that's that's slower than the gym and
over time it's very easy to to get into
this mire where you're thinking okay
I've been doing this for a year but what
what are my results been in the last six
months and yes and that is when people
do fall off and I actually think there's
side effects from falling off because
when I stopped meditating for a couple
of days I noticed that my inner
atmosphere becomes much more toxic and
that I'm much less likely to be able to
fend off the terrible ideas served up to
me by my inner narrator like you know
eat the seventy-fifth Oreo or say the
thing that's gonna ruin the next 48
hours of your marriage or whatever and
so I actually find that there is real
benefit to falling off sometimes so in
terms of the simple practice you know
people you you don't need to have pay
someone to give you a mantra you don't
need any specialized equipment for to
start it's really just about I mean you
can talk about how you did it but it's
just making a habit of sitting for 10
minutes a day is essentially yes you
should take what I say on this score
with a little bit of a grain of salt
because I am a co proprietor of a
meditation app so I do believe that
there is some utility to subscribing to
meditation apps but you don't need to
use an app so there are several ways you
can get started one definitely you
didn't start with one I did not that's
exactly right
I started meditating before apps were a
thing right well at least before
meditation apps were a thing
yeah 2009 I think I read a book where I
read a series of books but I think the
book the proximate cause for my actually
sitting down and starting to meditate
was a book by a former molecular
biologist by the name of Jon kabat-zinn
called wherever you go there you are and
he described the basic steps of
mindfulness meditation excuse me he
described the basic steps of mindfulness
meditation very clearly one sit in a
reasonably comfortable place and close
your eyes
to bring your full attention to the
feeling of your breath coming in and
going out three
whenever you get distracted start again
not super complicated now it can get
really interesting and complex in nice
ways from there hence the utility of
reading books or finding a person
teacher which is hard to do during a
pandemic or using an app but the basic
instructions which I did on my own for
at least a year before I finally went on
our meditation retreat are you know you
could take what I just told you and go
for yep and that that book is sort of
the the classic that is the entry the
entry way for for so many people
Jon kabat-zinn teaching for a long time
right down the road from from us in
Worcester Massachusetts in fact at UMass
Medical Center in Worcester Dan Harris
author of meditation for fidgety
skeptics and the book 10% happier I
really appreciate you sharing your story
with us down thanks for having me on